It's tempting.
Especially when you're starting to
look at screen reader accessibility,
to add tab index to seemingly
important elements like headers, for
instance, in order to help out the user.
That's actually counterproductive.
Normally, you only want to add focus
behavior to interactive controls like
buttons, tabs, drop downs, or anything
that the user might provide input to.
If you're worried about visually
impaired users missing out on your
content, don't be.
We're going to show in the next few
lessons how screen reader users
explore non interactive content.
So when you're adding a tab index
attribute, stop and ask yourself,
is this something the user
is going to interact with?
If the answer is no, you almost
certainly want to leave it alone
with the exception of a few caveats
which will cover in just a moment.